some traditional trees could disappear
from the british countryside forever as
changing weather patterns are creating
ideal conditions for diseases to spread
the national trust says it's trying to
build woodlands that are more resilient
to our changing climate but it's enough
being done to protect the world's
natural solutions and cece i know you've
done a lot of work on adaptation i mean
how important a role can nature play in
those projects trying to mitigate
against the effects of climate change
yeah sure um so there are many um
nature-based um solutions such as you
know one can build uh rain gardens or uh
or green roofs or permeable roads and
these are roads basically that absorb a
lot of water um so um in terms of i
actually like to highlight a um
initiative which is um happening in
china right now which is a country i
study quite a bit um the government has
launched a one trillion investment in um
this initiative called the sponge city
initiative but basically it's building
it's finding new ways of building city
services and roads which will absorb
water that stops from you know floods um
and it's like a
a new way of kind of constructing cities
um and by 2030 the government is
actually aiming to have 80 percent of
its urban areas um to be sponge-like so
these cities will absorb water you know
flood water i mean in essence um
very quickly and um there are some
preliminary results that are showing
that the investment in this kind of
resilience programs um are yielding 20
up to 20 times um investment returns so
it's really worth investing in in this
kind of resilient programs because um
they give you a lot of avoided damages
cece very briefly i mean we were hearing
about the national trust warning about
diseases in trees the problem is though
that climate change might affect some of
those nature-based solutions might may
very briefly if you can
oh yeah i mean trees are very you know
the lungs of the planets right we need
to protect them so um i think one a
nature-based solution is to not
kind of kind of plant more trees um and
in fact a study has shown um if you
plant a trillion trees we can have the
potential to save the planet and at
least to keep our you know global
temperature rise um below 1.5 degrees um
it has the potential to destroy but we
need to we need to protect trees okay
very quickly um richard i mean
obviously nature plays a big part in
mitigating against the effects of
climate change but it can be affected
deeply by it as well
yes and we need to understand that for
all kinds of reasons we rely upon nature
you know for a lot of the food that we
eat we rely on you know we need healthy
soil we need insect pollinators and all
of these things we know that wildlife is
shifting its ranges and and in response
to climate change we need to understand
that and adapt to it because basically
we need to you know humanity to be able
to survive well you know in the nature
of 40 50 years time as well as it does
now
you